je trouve que c'est le gouvernement qui
franchit la ligne rouge
on comprend parce qu'il y a plein de
gens je vous dis la vérité il y a plein
de gens qui vous détestent non mais
c'est vrai parce que à cause d'action
comme ça et en fait quand on parle avec
vous à chaque fois très sympathique je
vous trouve très sympathique je vous
trouve très intelligent et à chaque fois
quand on parle avec vous on se dit et
ben c'est pas des berlues mais rien
c'est quand même des gens qui ont voilà
qu'il faut quand même écouter donc on va
vous écouter dans un instant la ligne
rouge elle a été franchie par le
gouvernement déjà depuis pas mal de
temps mais encore plus depuis le 31
décembre 2022 parce que le gouvernement
l'État a été condamné à deux reprises
par le tribunal administratif
pour inaction climatique et à la
deuxième condamnation
[Musique]
enjoint le gouvernement de réparer de
prendre des mesures enfin efficaces pour
réparer le préjudice de l'inaction rien
n'a été fait rien n'a été fait et le
donc le 31 décembre le gouvernement est
rentré vraiment dans l'illégalité la
plus honteuse mais donc là la ce qui a
été fait c'est vraiment pour s'en
prendre au gouvernement
Florence Thibault pour vous est-ce que
c'est admissible d'avoir fait ça à
Matignon moi ce que je dis à chaque fois
et je le dis aussi pour vous un moment
on se dit c'est bien ce que vous faites
mais enfin vous allez au bout de vos
idées mais à un moment à un moment ça a
mal se terminer on voit des trucs ce qui
se passe sur sur le périph sur
l'autoroute sur il y a des gens au
moment qui ont mal le prendre on a tous
peur d'un jour qui est un drame pour un
de vos militants ou pour vous et c'est
vrai qu'on se pose aussi la question on
va en parler dans un instant Remond toi
je sais que toi tu penses qu'ils ont
franchi la ligne
vous avez envie de vivre il y en a qui
ont déjà assez vécu
hahaha
de ça comme nos idées comme si on
défendait
Rome politique alors que en fait pour
moi et pour tout un tas de personnes
c'est pas une idée que de vouloir vivre
c'est juste un instinct humain primaire
que de vouloir survivre dans un monde
qui est voué à à nous à nous abattre et
ça c'est scientifiquement reconnu donc à
la question est-ce qu'on a franchi la
ligne rouge pourquoi il y a de plus en
plus d'actions parce qu'il y a de plus
en plus urgences parce que la ligne
rouge a clairement été franchie et en
réalité c'est scientifiquement reconnu
que si on dépasse les deux degrés on va
condamner à mort des centaines de
millions de personnes c'est
scientifiquement reconnu on le sait
ensuite c'est juridiquement reconnu que
le gouvernement français n'est pas en
train de faire ce qu'il doit faire pour
qu'on reste sous les deux degrés et donc
ce que ça veut dire c'est que nos
tribunaux aujourd'hui le disent à tous
les Français votre gouvernement vous
condamne à mort c'est pas une idée
politique c'est un fait scientifique
juridique donc à quel moment est-ce que
la ligne rouge est franchie si c'est pas
au moment où des tribunaux reconnaissent
qu'un État est en train d'envoyer sa
propre population vers une mort certaine
à quel moment est-ce que la ligne rouge
est franchie
qu'est-ce que doit faire le gouvernement
alors tout de suite concrètement
pour rénover le parc immobilier français
qu'est-ce que doit faire le gouvernement
tout de suite à partir de demain pour
que les Français soient 100% écolo et
que se balade il se balade tous en
calèche en vélo en trottinette et en
roller attendez il va me répondre
le gouvernement vas-y moi je t'écoute
aussi j'ai envie que mes enfants vivent
dans un monde très bien qu'est-ce que
doit faire le gouvernement je veux
quelque chose de concret vas-y très
concrètement le gouvernement il peut
donner 13 milliards par an pour la
rénovation
les Français peuvent donner et surtout
les plus riches peuvent les Français qui
là peut-être pas bon sur les plus riches
peuvent donner mais les plus je lui
donneront pas ça sera toi les pleurer ça
c'est une solution
concrètement qu'est-ce que le
gouvernement peut
faire sur les camions
madame écoutez écoutez ce que fait le
gouvernement pour pour taper sur les
Français écoutez bien une fois que je
suis coulant chez colo tape sur les
camions taxe critères qu'on met tous sur
le pare-brise taxe sur la carte
rénovation
des billets d'avion taxe sur la reverse
mais il y a plein d'autres choses qui
pourraient faire des entreprises
obligées de faire des trucs par mail et
non par papier sinon des amandes et par
contre et les taxes sur les super
profits et les taxes sur leur profil sur
les pollueurs c'est les riches ça c'est
des riches une fois de plus les riches
vous ils vont se barrer vous ne pourrez
pas les toucher
depuis longtemps il pourrait très bien
il pourrait très bien français
qui ne peut plus rentrer dans une ville
parce que sa voiture pollue et qui doit
aller travailler
et en particulier si on parle des
passoires thermiques qui concerne 12
millions de personnes il y a un rapport
du ministère de la transition
énergétique de notre gouvernement qui
dit que chaque année ça a un coût de 10
milliards en termes de soins de santé
énergétique globale qu'on demande
et que l'Assemblée nationale était prête
et avait voté de façon majoritaire
avec un budget qui correspondait aux
besoins d'une rénovation sur plusieurs
années avec 13 milliards par an et vous
entend jamais
il a raison
ils viennent ils sont obsédés par les
fenêtres mais tu sais faut qu'on parle
de la France
va pas sonner mon sens en fait la France
va pas sauver le monde un ensemble
et vous savez combien de population
c'est le groupe aux autres
c'est pas combien on pèse dans les
émissions
Thibault Thibault pourquoi parle de la
France parce que la France 1%
mais chacun peut commencer
de faire des brushings euh Castaldi mais
juste évidemment que votre cause ananas
mais quand on fait une action il faut
que il faut qu'elle puisse être audible
en ce moment la France franchement les
Français le 15 du mois ils savent pas
comment ils vont bien sûr il reste
jusqu'à la fin du mois en ce moment il y
a que il y a que des problèmes il y a la
guerre en Ukraine donc les albums que
vous faites là qui sont dans un contexte
qui est totalement perturbé vous êtes
les gens ils se disent on s'en fout
complètement et c'est ça le problème
les Français
non non le mecs
électricités
hier sur vous
parlait pas du fait que ça pollué
de leur facture
énergie aujourd'hui
vous faites des actions pour être pour
que les gens vous comprennent je vous
dis en ce moment en ce moment la France
et d'ailleurs le monde globalement quand
vous faites ça les gens ils disent mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils viennent nous emmerder
avec tout ce qui se passe moi je peux
pas finir en moi moi je peux pas vivre
moi j'ai des problèmes de la guerre
pour vous soigner ma grippe vous prenez
vous croyez vous croyez que les Français
aller voir les politiques et je vais
pouvoir les politiques tu leur dis ah
bah ils emmerdent les politiques
la dernière fois on leur a dit aller
voir le reste c'est pas vrai c'est
responsable en question là elle a raison
Valérie là-dessus c'est c'est sûr non
sur les centrales nucléaires
ouvrir les centrales nucléaires alors
est-ce qu'on a besoin parce que les
écoles ont voulu qu'on les ferme
absolument en Allemagne
en Allemagne c'est catastrophique donc
nous est-ce qu'on a besoin les
boulangers c'est es catastrophique on a
vu notre état de d'électricité c'est
catastrophique est-ce qu'on a besoin de
tout de toutes ces centrales nucléaires
est-ce que vous êtes pour ou contre
est-ce que vous êtes pour la
décroissance
énergétique son dont on parle
aujourd'hui c'est comment est-ce qu'on
comment est-ce qu'on peut permettre aux
gens mieux vivre de mieux vivre
je vous parle de la France aujourd'hui
c'est comment est-ce qu'on peut dépenser
moins d'énergie à la maison et
aujourd'hui c'est en rénovant des
bâtiments
on leur dit quoi alors justement on aura
des boulangers c'est que si les
bâtiments en France sont rénovés il
dépense
tout le monde a des logements
la peinture qui vous avait aspergé dans
les ministères est-ce qu'elle pollue pas
mais est-ce que vous voulez quand même
recentrer un peu le sujet est-ce que
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dire des citoyens
exemplaires pourquoi est-ce que on fait
des actions qui nous emmènent
devant les tribunes au moins je vais
être sur le bon des accusés lundi le 9
janvier
je suis passif de deux ans de prison
parce que en tant que citoyen j'ai
ressenti que mon gouvernement qui doit
me protéger ne fait pas le premier des
le premier pas minimum pour que
le pays dans lequel je vis et tout ce
que j'aime mes enfants vivent dans 15-20
ans
le nombre de gens qui sont d'accord avec
vous vous rendez compte le nombre de
boulanger de tout ça de tout qui
subissent une injustice vous vous rendez
bien compte que l'humanité toute entière
est hypnotisée alors qu'elle va mourir
et que le tu nous demandait si on
voulait vivre moi je sais que comme
Artus Bertrand elle est trop tard pour
être pessimiste donc moi je trouve que
l'image d'une dégradation d'un truc
public la mesure où les enfants ferment
leurs oreilles au sermon et ils ouvrent
leurs yeux à l'exemple je trouve que ce
n'est pas un exemple et je que si demain
et ben tous les mecs vont taguer tous
les monuments de trucs et ben ça va pas
faire beaucoup avancer et puis je vais
revenir je suis un truc que vous avez
dit qui me fait un peu sourire mais moi
je suis un humoriste tu comprends que
vous avez dit les riches il pourrait
redonner au pauvres si tu veux mon
pauvre vieux est-ce que tu connais un
seul risque Simone je crois qu'on a
assez gagné on va redonner maintenant tu
vois ça n'existe pas c'est des questions
politiques publiques de toute façon les
coûts à ne pas agir ça c'est prouver les
coûts à ne pas agir vont être bien plus
élevés que les coûts à agir donc on peut
pas déjà se dire que on peut pas agir
parce que ça coûte trop cher la question
c'est où est-ce qu'on va chercher
l'argent
qu'est-ce que ça change ta question les
gens ils comprennent pas etc on est allé
chercher les coupables là où ils sont
aujourd'hui et hier devant leur bureau
as-tu peu les chercher
pour que les Français sachent que ceux
qui les gouvernent ne les protègent pas
et c'est ça le message
et la question qu'on devait leur poser
c'est où est-ce qu'ils sont pourquoi ils
se cachent dans leur bureau pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'est pas là en train de
débattre avec eux je suis en train de
parler avec toi avec toi et pourquoi
est-ce que là il y a pas quelqu'un du
gouvernement qui est assis à cette table
pourquoi est-ce qu'il débarque pas avec
nous alors est-ce qu'il se cache on va
leur demander on pourra on pourra faire
un démarrage je pense que tout à fait
prévenir juste je suis pas sûr qu'il
serait prêt à venir on leur a envoyé
apparemment la première ministre
maintenant elle a notre numéro de
téléphone qu'il aurait été donné
au téléphone ça fait un an qu'ils savent
qu'ils vont venir enlever leur poser une
question
j'aimerais Daniel Guichard et après
Delphine parce que Delphine c'est quand
même très sincèrement je respecte vos
idées la façon dont vous avez envie de
défendre vos convictions vous avez l'air
complètement passionné donc ça c'est
respectable je suis pas persuadé que
votre méthode soit la meilleure non pas
dans ce que vous faites quand vous filez
de la peinture chez le Premier ministre
ou la première mise mais dans votre
façon de raisonner vous raisonner en
disant on sait et à partir du moment où
c'est on va vous dire que vous devez
savoir aussi si vous voulez réussir
quelque chose c'est pas moi qui veut
vous le dire il manque un arabe en face
qui est humoriste la même chose essayez
de réunir des gens essayez de les
convaincre paisiblement faites quelque
chose d'extraordinaire comme ça c'est
très beau artistiquement et après de
dire on pourrait paisiblement expliqué
or vous n'expliquez pas paisiblement
vous êtes là en imposition en disant
est-ce que tu veux vivre mais moi 40 ans
qu'on explique visiblement
n'est pas d'accord ça veut pas dire que
ceux qui sont pas d'accord en raison
d'accord c'est de la science c'est pas
de la science le rapport du Gex c'est
pas de la science ce sont des
techniciens qui sont pas d'accord entre
eux mais en France on est en France en
2022 sur sur ton plateau Cyril et tu as
des invités qui disent que le GIEC le
rapport du GIEC est-ce que j'ai parlé
plus grands scientifiques c'est pas de
la science j'ai des gens qui sont du
GIEC je suis les choses ils sont pas
tous d'accord les uns avec les autres et
ils sont des milliers 97 %
je dis que vous y prenez mal que si vous
voulez qu'on vous aime qu'on vous suit
essayer de convaincre essayez pas d'être
autoritaire comme ça parce que ce genre
de truc me gonfle c'est tout alors moi
je vais pas être autoritaire je vais
juste rappeler
alors
si on condamné notre état
je ne sais pas pourquoi de quoi ils ont
été condamnés et c'est ça qu'il faut
expliquer calmement parce que ils se
sont engagés aux dans les accords de
Paris à diminuer les missions de gaz à
effet de serre pour essayer qu'on aille
pas nouveau ça fait longtemps que ça
voilà très bien et comme dans la période
2015 2018 grâce à l'engagement dans des
pétitions de de plus de 2 millions de
Français de quatre associations il y a
eu une saisine de la justice et le
gouvernement est très condamné et
inaction j'ai pas fini et et il vous a
posé une question importante tout à
l'heure le CO2 l'effet de serre est-ce
que vous êtes pour ou contre l'énergie
nucléaire c'est pas parfait
on continue nucléaire ou on arrête le
nucléaire
on a un gosse
la rénovation énergétique nous inviter à
venir ici et vous voulez faire un débat
sur le menu
très important qui me dit bonsoir
impossible de réaliser des travaux de
rénovation aussi peu de temps pas assez
d'entreprise et de personnels
disponibles et l'isolation par intérêt
par l'intérieur fait perdre des mètres
carrés et par l'extérieur les archives
des autres bâtiments de France n'en
veulent pas la fabrication des fenêtres
minimum 6 mois donc c'est impossible
voilà c'est impossible complexe c'est
pour ça qu'il faut commencer dès
maintenant et les choses
extrêmement bien décrite par les gens
qui ont travaillé dans la convention
citoyenne pour les climats ça a été
repris aussi par des associations
extrêmement
estimable et respectable comme
la Fondation Abbé Pierre il y a plein de
gens qui savent très bien on sait
comment faire on connaît les solutions
et juste l'association des artisans du
bâtiment de France là encore dit cette
année au moment justement il y avait la
loi qui est en train de voter que ils
sont en mesure de faire les travaux et
qu'ils attendent des commentaires
et on a un sort de de d'élèves modèle du
monde entier
on crève tout pareil à cause de la Chine
vous croyez qu'il y aura un paradis
comme ça
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on fasse rien
élève voilà exactement
c'est engagé à faire des choses on les
respecte pas comment on peut dire qu'on
a un bon élève c'est comme dirait engagé
à diminuer nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de
40,9 %
vous trouvez que c'est bien je trouve
que c'est pas si mal par rapport
s'il vous plaît
Delphine c'est quand même son sujet non
en fait c'est je trouve le débat
surréaliste parce qu'il n'y a pas de
débat et normalement ils ont été trop
loin parce que revenons des bas ils ont
été trop loin
moi je trouve que vous êtes des héros et
Oli au lieu de de au lieu d'avoir un
débat en fait on devrait juste vous
applaudir et vous dire merci et vous
dire que vous venez presque un peu trop
tard et qu'en fait on aurait dû être
avec vous déjà et et en fait il faut pas
qu'on vous soutienne demain on aurait dû
vous soutenir hier et être encore plus
nombreux et quand vous dites la France
ouais mais si on est les seules à faire
ça et et
oui pas de problème
il faut bien je suis d'accord pour mes
enfants pour nos enfants il faut il faut
bien que quelqu'un commence je veux dire
socialement et ben il y a une fois un
pays qui a commencé puis ensuite il y a
eu les droits de leur mais tu crois
vraiment que la France crois que les
gens ils vont suivre la France
a taper de la France
la France on a aucun poids qu'avec ta
tête tu vas dire que le responsabilité
tu vas arriver devant les Chinois
[Musique]
l'Europe c'est la dernière roue du
carrosse le samedi
mais tu dors dis-lui Géraldine et non on
a un vieux continent
voilà on est cuit on était comme on peut
on essaie de colmater les brèches
qui nous regarde est-ce que si demain
c'est 2 millions de personnes prennent
leur bombe de peinture et repeignent
tout en orange est-ce que ça va changer
quelque chose la bombe parce que c'est
vous ce que c'est ce que vous incitez à
faire mais la bande de peinture genre
symboliquement moi elle me parle
énormément parce que ça ce gouver enfin
c'est une action me fait honte quand
j'entends le président de la République
qui le jour où il rentre dans
l'illégalité la plus idiomineuse le 31
décembre il dit qui pouvait prévoir la
crise climatique
je trouve que c'est trop facile d'aller
chercher
admirable parmi les gens qui sont venus
est-ce que vous avez Jean-Marie
c'est trop facile nucléaire c'est votre
ami François Hollande absolument sous la
pression des écolos pour
tu veux d'écouter la pression des meufs
il en a fait des conneries par rapport
à lui qu'on est dans la merde
c'est lui ça sert à rien c'est trop tard
c'est trop facile de dire ça parce que
là tu ne fais rien
qui est condamné
pour
mais c'est pas oui c'est les
gouvernements d'avant du gouvernement
d'avance aussi
vraiment on fait déjà beaucoup le
tribunaux disent qu'on en fait pas assez
comment est-ce que vous pouvez dire
qu'on en fait beaucoup alors que nos
tribunaux en font pas assez c'est quoi
c'est comme dire à quelqu'un qui roule à
150 sur l'autoroute non mais j'ai déjà
fait un effort pour pas rouler trop vite
alors qu'on lui dit non c'est limité à
130 vous êtes à 150 là il vous êtes en
train de dire non
objectif je trouve qu'il a raison les
tribunaux ont dit le nombre de conneries
que les tribunaux peuvent dire c'est
on est abandonné si on n'est pas fini
parce que disent les tribunaux alors on
va voir ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs
regardez oui
je parle mais bon l'engagement c'est
c'est 40%
tout le monde veut bien comprendre moi
je veux bien comprendre
est-ce qu'on peut donner la parole il va
faire on va finir par lui par Superman
là celui qui veut sauver le monde là
Gilles Verdez
rien parce que c'est trop tard il n'est
jamais trop tard pour l'urgence et pour
sauver le monde
français tout ça parce que j'ai arrêté
les Français les Français on fait que ça
mais évidemment qu'on est tous surtaxé
mais si on ne fait rien le monde va
mourir est-ce que vous voulez
pourquoi
c'est comme les masques
isolé c'est factures
oui à 68 % de moins 31% en tout cas
merci tu sais combien de pour cent des
des Français pense que le gouvernement
n'en fait pas assez parce qu'on a posé
quatre quatre 80 % des Français je suis
d'accord 80% des Français je pense que
le gouvernement c'est pour ça pas assez
sur les questions climatiques c'est ça
la statue on en fait beaucoup plus que
les autres est-ce qu'on peut poser la
question est-ce que ça soit est-ce que
c'est normal que je me retrouve devant
le tribunal sur le banc des accusés
alors que le gouvernement
lui il est même pas ici pour se défendre
c'est un méprises la population à ce
moment-là on fait tout n'importe quoi
les gilets jaunes on leur a tiré dessus
il se met les mains pour parce qu'il
voulait bouffer ils ont été devant les
tribunaux vous pouvez lancer de la
peinture vous foutez le bordel parce que
il faut des fenêtres alors je comprends
je le veux je suis comme vous je suis
dans le combat écolo mais faudrait vous
laisser tranquille et là faudrait vous
dire bon partez on va nettoyer non
madame vous partez pas on va pas
nettoyer vous allez passer devant un
tribunal c'est comme ça comme il a dit
merci
ce que je voudrais mettre en avant
normal que des personnes comme moi autre
chose à faire d'abord
c'est plus dur de la rentrée après donc
après faut nettoyer quoi
[Applaudissements]
de prendre les choses en main et de et
de dire au monde il y a des choses à
faire on sait quoi on les faire
des décisions
il ne parle pas de la pollution de
carbone il ne parle pas des pays qui
polluent n'empêche pas le débat il parle
des McDonald's
merci merci à tous allez juste Cyril
avant qu'on finisse là c'est la
troisième c'est la troisième fois qu'on
est invité merci de venir plateau merci
en tout cas à chaque fois qu'on vient on
en parle entre nous c'est super il y a
des gens qui sont pour il y a des gens
qui sont contre mais